you
this series now contains over a dozen
videos presenting the basic grammatical
features of vulgar latin and the romance
languages each video contained many
examples pronounced out loud but none of
them address the topic of pronunciation
directly this video finally offers a
rough sketch of the pronunciation of
vulgar latin and early romance with some
notes on how that pronunciation
developed and splintered as proto
romance divided into the modern Romance
languages
classical Latin valves had two values
short and lung the name refers to how
long the vowel is held short versus long
ah you can hear that long vowels are
held out longer in time in vulgar latin
the quality of a vowel became a major
difference between short and long vowels
some vowels sound different even if they
weren't held longer shorter long and
short ah
but short a long a short o long o short
o long ooh
for example been a has a short a well
poder a has a long a notice how crucial
the differences in some proto romance
words the all in solo is short but the o
in so low is long you can see that long
mark macron above the long vowel
sometimes a short mark is used above
short vowels but usually the vowels are
written unmarked outside of educational
materials the length of AA is trivial
the modern languages mostly have whether
the vowel was a long or short and Latin
but the historical length of other
vowels matters more often
sometimes what were once just long and
short versions of the same vowel or
spelled quite differently in the modern
Romance languages for example the verb
bolted he can with a short all comes out
as Spanish way they French Bert old
Italian both it
classical Latin used the vowel
combinations I and ow which tended to
but didn't always merge with the vowels
a and oh here's the word Powell and some
of its modern cognates
and this is the word quest yone which
was regularly pronounced questi on it in
early romance
diphthongs also occur for short a and
short all Bennett Spanish DNA Italian
DNA French en
or both it Spanish way the French /
Romanian wotty
most consonants are pronounced very much
as they are in English but pay attention
to these ones the stops written p t and
c are unaspirated so they're pronounced
without that puff of air in or H sound
that often accompanies them in English
so this word is pronounced bathra not
Patrick this is do not - and this one is
gallu rather than callo
consider this an important note for
English speakers
the you in WA and quoi doesn't fall
silent in vulgar latin so lingua and
lingua or aqua and aqua or quando
instead of french gong and romanian gund
late latin speakers dropped their H's so
earlier latin hora became vulgar latin
hora the letter r' was drilled like roma
or trace v was pronounced v not were
like it was in classical latin v nu v
later merges with B and a few languages
including Spanish which has beena
double consonants were pronounced long
just as they still are an Italian flama
ela the letters C and G represented
stops gasa Kelo both with a cuff sound
gusto and Genta both with a gust sound
eventually see was softened before en i
originally palatalized to something like
gia and eventually son cha orsa cello
spanish PLO romanian chair the same
thing happens to g or gym before ii and
i which comes to sound like juh juh and
later huh in spanish Genta portuguese eh
italian Genta spanish st. a uniquely
Sardinian doesn't do that so G and C
stay close to their original cut and Gus
sounds before enin Sardinian cello
French CL Sicilian shallow but Sardinian
k Lou
keya and gear are examples of
palatalization vulgar latin consonants
turn palatal by pronouncing a short yeah
after the consonant and before another
vowel this Y sound is written with an i'
or sometimes with J so N or nut is
palatalized in the word value L gets
palatalized in Mulia a T is palatalized
in gratia this little Y sound has a
lasting impact on later Romance words
for example that palatalized T in gratia
doesn't stay at e thanks to
palatalization that gia eventually
becomes a son in French gasps sir in
Italian Grazia and thir in Spanish
Gracia palatal consonants don't always
get treated the same either take the
proto Romance word venue which has the
palatal new sound in Portuguese and
Galician this comes out as venue and
venue but Italian and Spanish have van
Gogh and Bengal which no longer have
palatal sounds Romance consonants were
sometimes softened between valves and
this was routinely the case in Western
Romance languages like French Spanish
Catalan oxygen and Portuguese this
process called Lanisha n-- explains why
the final T in quantity becomes voiced D
and Portuguese condado
a the sound in spanish gonzalo and
disappears entirely in caribbean spanish
canal this is also how a single s comes
to sound like Z between two vowels and
many Romance languages aside from
Spanish and Romanian Casa
Italian Gazza Portuguese Casa
but Romanian casa
vulgar latin and early romance syllables
often contain a vowel or a consonant
plus vowel
Betty Kulu a single consonant may close
a syllable facto consonant clusters were
also found like plug in placket or the
SCARA inscripted most words had a
prominent louder syllable and this
stressed syllable was typically the
second to last one like in boolean or
Casa sometimes it was the third to last
syllable like in Prospero or petit Kulu
the other syllables were unstressed
unstressed syllables were sometimes cut
out this happened at the end of words
particularly in Romanian French oxygen
Catalan and Romansh Prospero becomes
French postbag which lost its final
syllable and solid becomes Spanish Sun
without that final ii sometimes the
middle syllable was cut out betty colu
was shortened to Betty clue and later
Spanish Bella guru this has been but a
rough sketch of vulgar latin and romance
pronunciation it's meant to help you
understand the pronunciation of words
throughout the rest of this grammar of
romance but it's also a springboard for
learning more about the pronunciation of
Latin of individual Romance languages
and of the historical sound changes that
took place between them violating and
thanks for learning with me
you